So the other law that we're
going to talk about is
the Digital Millennium Copyright Act or
popularly known as the DMCA.
And this has to do with,
we discussed intellectual property.
So content,
digital content software, and
the problem it helps
to address is piracy.
Illegal copying for example or
theft of these kind of digital objects.
That's what DMCA covers.
So first of all,
it says that digital objects,
the kind I was talking about,
actually can be copyrighted.
So you have protections
that you get when you're
able to obtain a copyright on something.
Well, the same thing now applies to,
that was the non-digital law,
the same thing now applies
to digital objects.
Well, DMCA says it is a crime for
you to circumvent and disable
any measures that are there that have to
do with copy protection and anti-piracy.
So it is built into the object,
it sort of and
undo that, and that act is
considered illegal if you do that.
It also not only can't do that, it
makes it criminal for you to actually,
whatever idea that you had to produce
something based on that, manufacture it.
And then sell and distribute it so
somebody else can defeat the copy
protection or the anti-piracy
measures that are in place.
So essentially what we're saying is
that we need to protect those and
it's illegal to undo those
protections and sort of indulge in
commerce that allows you to
let other people do the same.